[Music]
horn in Cherry Hill New Jersey outside
of Philadelphia a chef Greg Burnett grew
up in a true food family his grandfather
owned a butcher shop in a market and his
mother ran a restaurant of her own
after earning culinary and hospitality
degrees he worked for renowned chef Jean
George first at his New York restaurants
then as a chef trainer around the globe
before becoming executive chef at New
York's Tocqueville in 2012 he came back
to Philadelphia opening Vernick Food &
Drink celebrated for no-fuss new
American cooking this year the
Philadelphia Inquirer called it the best
restaurant in the city and Vernick just
took home the 2017 James Beard Award for
Best Chef in the mid-atlantic region
chef Greg verdict welcome to the dish
congratulations thank you very much no
come on with it if you like to get that
it felt a little crazy you know I didn't
exactly know what to do when you're up
there I kind of wish I could hit rewind
and do it again cuz I'm getting made fun
of a lot for my little little speech I
made but it was great it was an honor
that's genuine emotion when you sit
there what is this wonderful meal that
we have here so we did sort of like a
little summer picnic situation I think
we need to start with a cocktail first
if we do right we did like our summer
watermelon cocktail with ginger and gin
and some cucumber and fresh lime juice
and there's remoteness as well and over
here because I'm taking it all yeah just
like very really nice fresh cocktail
yeah and then we have a couple sort of
summery salad some grilled romaine with
stone fruits quinoa salad with grilled
corn and blue cheese a beautiful tomato
tart and then whole roasted leg of lamb
with mustard and anchovy and then last
we did a cannoli stuffed with strawberry
mousse last but certainly not least chef
Alina I mean we could start with that if
you want we oftentimes we do you started
as a kid that really just grew up in a
kitchen in restaurants I mentioned the
background how did that shape you being
like that I mean it was it was my
childhood it's a lot of my memory
revolves around being in my mom's
restaurant she had like a little
luncheonette and my grand
father and I would be playing in the
back making little sandwiches and salads
and they all were disgusting but he
would eat them and I would like sample
him on them and then before that my
grandfather had a butcher shop in
Philadelphia so it's it's a little bit
of third-generation food business so you
know it's been really nice and when you
were a teenager your parents said you're
not going to camp you're gonna get a job
yeah yeah I wasn't happy about that I
just remember like I was 13 and they
were they were like you can't go to camp
anymore you need to get a job and so we
we made up like a fake resume with my
grades and like my activities and I
liked basketball and stuff and we drove
up and down the Jersey Shore just
resumes and finally somebody like
accepted it and interviewed me on the
spot and you know I don't know if I
should say this but I lied to them I
said I know how to cook and I had no
idea I got back in the car and I was
like mom I got a job and she's like I
told her the story and she's like what
you lied so yeah so I guess it worked
out great but I also a little life
lesson at the same time you ended up
working with John George training chefs
all around the world yeah what was that
experience like it was amazing I mean I
felt like for a moment I the greatest
chef job in the world in a lot of ways I
was a fly on the wall because you get to
see you know a hotel come to life not
just a restaurant but you get to sort of
be a fly on the wall and see everything
happen it's a great business education
if you yeah you know it was it was
amazing and at the same time I was sort
of building a curriculum as to what it
would take to open my own restaurant
so you know it was a lot of hotel out of
time on the road in hotels but um you
know every opening we got a little bit
better and I got a little more
experienced and to the point where I was
like you know I think I could do this
myself and you did and you and your wife
Julie back in Philadelphia why was it so
important for you to go back home and do
this Philadelphia's home it's always
been home
it was always sort of a conversation we
this is it's the third city we lived in
I love living in cities I love New York
I
Boston but there is no like sense of
home like Philadelphia was and now we
have a family there and it's just it
just is a special place to us it really
does feel like home well it sounds like
you have a special place there now given
what's happening with your restaurants
we're having a lot of fun that's great
it is the dish so as I have you sign it
let me ask you if you could have a meal
with anyone pastor present who would it
be I really think it'd be cool to have
all of like my past mentors sit down
with me and sort of break bread people
like John George and Greg brain in and
mark la Pico and Ken Oringer sort of a
small group of people who like taught me
the ways I'd be amazing maybe have
everybody cook a little something too
and what I became like you know thanks
to you guys that's right yeah chef Greg
verdict thank you thank you guys very
much and for more on Greg Vernick and
the dish you can head to our website at
CBS this morning dot-com